Speaker 1: Much is being made, particularly
by right wing media, about an utterance that
President Joe Biden made yesterday, which some
are saying is a sign that he is not planning to
run for reelection in 2024. Now, there's been a
lot of attention on the Republican side over the
last several weeks. The reason for that attention
has been that failed. Former President Donald
Trump announced he's running again. Despite that,
Ron DeSantis, the recently reelected governor of
Florida, is polling really well, even though he
hasn't actually announced that he's running for
anything. The Republicans, civil war, etc..
So there have been a lot of reasons why the
focus has been on the Republican side. But
there's another element to this, which is
that the suspicion that Joe Biden is not really
interested in running for reelection has been to
some degree supplanted by the growing belief that
Joe Biden will run for reelection and polling that
looks pretty okay for Joe Biden. And suddenly
headlines like this one appeared yesterday,
for example, in the right leaning Washington
Examiner. I don't know about that. Biden casts
doubt on 2024 run. So what exactly happened? Well,
let's just look at the video. What you are going
to see here is Joe Biden delivering a statement at
the White House, a tribal nations summit. And as
he is wrapping up, someone from the crowd seems to
shout out four more years and Joe Biden seems to
respond. I don't know about that. That's the best
assessment that we have, although it's not totally
clear. Let's take a look at it and then discuss.
Speaker 2: As my grandfather training, I would say
that's the Irish of it. Thank you all very much.
Speaker 1:
Okay. Four more years. I don't know about that.
So is that what was said? It seems to be. I mean,
I think I heard four more years and then I
don't know about that. Let's listen to it
one more time. I think it would.
Speaker 2: Say that's the
Irish of it. Thank you all very much.
Speaker 1: Thanks. Oh, I don't know about that.
Is too much being made of this? I think so.
I don't have any special insight into whether
Joe Biden is or isn't going to run. If you had
asked me nine months ago, I would have said,
I think Joe Biden is definitely not running for
reelection today. I think it's much more likely
that he will run for reelection. And part of
this has to do with legislative achievements,
approval rating, recovery, circumstantial elements
to this. There's a lot of different reasons,
but I'm separating my opinion from what
we saw there. I think it is just as likely
as what Joe Biden met was. This isn't the venue
in which we're going to talk about my campaign,
because we're here for the Tribal Nations
Summit. That would be consistent with Joe
Biden's personality and his kind of modus
operandi. I think it's just as likely that
it's that as it is Joe Biden saying, I don't
know that I'm going to be running. And in fact,
when you really think about it, is it likely that
Joe Biden would let slip, arguably for the first
time in a more formal capacity that he might not
run in response to an utterance from the crowd at
an event about something completely different?
I don't think so. If Joe Biden is going to tell
us I don't know that I'm running in 24. I don't
think it's going to be in a venue like this in
reaction to something yelled out from the crowd.
Now, when it comes to the polling question. It is
interesting to take a look at some of the
relatively new polling that we have seen
for 2024. These are, of course, hypothetical
polls and it's really a pretty mixed bag here.
You see that an Emerson College poll that's
an A-minus rated pollster has it as Biden,
DeSantis, DeSantis plus four. But in Biden
versus Trump, it has it even. On the other hand,
you look at the Marquette University Law School
poll also, that's an AB rated pollster pretty
good. They have Biden even with the Santos in one
poll, DeSantis slightly ahead in a different poll,
and then Biden well ahead of Donald Trump. And
then you go back to a premise poll, not a rated
pollster at all. They have DeSantis plus four over
Biden, but Biden plus six over Trump. So the gist
of the polling right now contains two pieces of
important data. Number one against Trump. Biden
seems to poll pretty well. And against DeSantis,
Biden polls less. Well, that's the trend. And
depending on which poll you look at, the specific
numbers differ. We are going to have to wait and
see. I don't know what Biden heard in the moment.
I don't 100% know what Biden said, but I don't
believe Biden would reveal possibly not running
in that sort of venue and in that sort of format